all right uh let's get into the news of
the day april 1. all of which or any of
which may be fake news thanks to the
calendar but uh ron rivera had a press
conference they saw a little bit of it
earlier when he was talking about seeing
his parents after he got his second
second vaccination shot he also was
asked about how he feels regarding the
team's quarterback situation moving into
the future here's rivera
and how do you feel about the concept of
the quarterback of the future you need
your quote-unquote quarterback of the
future
is that a pressure to define that now
this year
no
no no and i say that just because of the
fact that if you put all the other
pieces in the place
and and now you start going forward when
that guy does show up when that guy is
in the right position you can grab him i
went through it the other way my first
in as a head coach in carolina we
drafted the quarterback of the future
for us in the first round uh and he was
lo and behold the immediate future i've
always thought wow you know if if you
could do it the other way where you put
all the other pieces around and then go
out and get your quarterback
man that might be a pretty good
situation too
a lot of teams did that i've seen a lot
of teams that have have had
things in place and then drafted their
quarterback the next year
this could be one of these situations
where we
put all the other pieces in place and a
year or two from now the right guy's
there and we can make that move
but we'll see i mean again you just
never really know
uh until you get there
and look washington right now try oh no
now will you please stop you know when i
heard him can can we please get rid of
that that was a lifetime ago take that
off the screen or i'm getting up and i'm
walking out right now and that's not an
april fool's day gag any time that
phrase gets used twice in close
proximity matt casey's antenna go up he
did it earlier this week when shireen
williams used that phrase twice he says
in my ear oh there's a book about that
it's like just shut up just let it go
it's not funny anymore it's as funny as
tom brady's april fool's day gag i
thought anyway funny
well nobody asked you anyway
the washington football team has a
grizzled veteran with an awesome beard
who will be the quarterback this year
and behind him it's kyle allen a guy who
did okay in carolina in 2019 and okay
last year until he got injured then
taylor heineke who was surprisingly
effective in the wild card loss to the
buccaneers but you can't play like that
the way he did
basically all out doing everything he
can to show that he can play to the
point where he injured himself like
seven times during the game that's not
going to work either at some point
they've got to make a move for a
long-term quarterback and for now
they're just going to tread water until
the opportunity arises for them to get
their long-term quarterback but they're
not going to be a consistent year in and
year out contender at a high level
there'll be a contender to win the
division but
they could bring back heath schuler and
be a contender to win the division in
that division but they're not going to
be a high-end contender until they get a
true great quarterback
certainly not and the thing is i think
we all want to kind of praise washington
for making the playoffs in the first
year of ron rivera's tenure and it is
great you know whenever you win a
division that's something to write home
about i do believe that however when you
think about it they were seven and nine
they go into the postseason they have to
play tyler heineken he plays a good game
but i agree with you mike
that type of play the way he did it it's
not sustainable over the course of a 17
game regular season now so look i think
having ryan fitzpat
patrick is good for right now you would
probably rather just have him be a
bridge quarterback like the miami
dolphins did because i'm gonna say it
before you do uh of course fitzmagic
always turns into fits tragic at some
point along the road so with because you
don't really have that right now i think
that the washington football team has to
say all right we're maybe going to take
a look at some of these quarterbacks
that might be available to us at 19
overall with the thought that they could
sit for a year or maybe we wait until
the second round and if one of those
guys is there i'm talking about guys
like come on kyle trask if one of those
guys is there and they kind of believe
in him then maybe you pick him you let
him sit in your system and you say maybe
you can be our guy but if you don't
believe in one of those guys then you
could still make the postseason with the
roster as it's currently constructed
around the quarterback as opposed to
with the quarterback
and i really do think that the decision
to add ryan fitzpatrick allows
washington
the ability to at least create the
impression they're not desperate for a
quarterback with the 19th overall pick
in the draft same thing with the bears
at 20 and andy dalton once they signed
him
it's not as obvious at that point that
you'd better jump those teams if you
want to draft a guy in the teens because
they're ready and willing and able to
take someone who slides into their lap
but with with all this buzz in recent
days miles of
of the cluster of quarterbacks that may
come off the board one two three four
five
i don't know
if there's going to be anybody who
justifies being picked
in the 19 or 20 spot because i think all
five of the top guys
are going to be gone by the time we get
maybe to 10 maybe to six but definitely
they could go in the top ten so it won't
matter and there won't be an opportunity
for washington at 19 to take a
quarterback so you just tread water
until next year or you take a lower
level guy
who you can try to develop quietly and
there won't be the expectation that he
comes in and plays right away and then
maybe by next year he could compete to
be the the starting quarterback
right one of the things that i thought
uh was interesting that ron rivera was
talking about was basically how he was
saying you know we built the thing with
the qb when i was in carolina and now i
always thought it might be good to try
to build it around the qb and then put
in the qb later so i think that there is
sort of a method to that now do most
teams do it like that at this point in
you know our nfl
history not really i mean you have to be
able to make sure that you have the qb
in order to really become the super bowl
contender and a lot of teams obviously
do that when the qb is still on the
rookie contract i mean the best example
i can think of with that would be the
kansas city chiefs where they clearly
had a playoff caliber team but
alex smith was unfortunately one of the
weaker spots on that squad i mean even
though he was a good quarterback he
wasn't a great quarterback so what did
they do they traded up they get patrick
mahomes they win the super bowl one year
and now they've been back in it the next
year so look i think if washington wants
to take that approach it's a decent
approach but it does mean that you have
to be right when you figure out the qb
that you want um for the future mike and
there's a good book about that isn't
there
you said for the future that one has not
been written yet and now
will be unless unless you'd like to feel
free you can have the title actually
titles can't be copyrighted uh
so i'm told
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports